Ça a commencé !
♪ Je veux tes yeux ♪
Moi !
J'ai des petits TOC.
Et cette histoire,
t'auras la suite à Montréal.
Tu veux que je fasse un bisou
à la caméra
comme Ariana Grande ?
*Rot*
Je préfère que tu mettes ça.
*Rires*
Bon, bon, bon, bon, bon.
♪ Balance ton quoi ♪
♪ Un jour
Peut-être ça changera ♪
♪ Balance ton quoi ♪
Clap !
Bonsoir à tous,
je ne peux pas être
parmi vous ce soir
parce que je suis à New York
pour des concerts.
On est là parce que
ça pouvait pas être
les vacances tout le temps
et du coup,
on va enregistrer une session.
Et on profite de ce cadre,
très moche,
qu'est Manhattan,
pour l'enregistrer.
♪ Perdus ♪
♪ Tous ces gens
m'avaient prévenue ♪
J'avais vraiment un rêve,
c'était de jouer à New York.
C'est une ville absolument incroyable
mais très, très rude.
T'as à la fois l'impression
que tout est possible
mais aussi que rien n'est possible.
Genre le rêve américain !
Et j'avais vraiment envie
d'y être pour me dire :
“J'y suis pour faire ce que j'aime
et pour faire mon métier."
Alors là, j'avais
des petites promos
et je vais aller
me reposer parce qu'après,
je vais aller en sound check
à la salle.
Bisous !
Viens Brice,
on va voir s'il y a de la place.
- Tournée aux États-Unis,
qu'ils disaient.
- Qu'ils disaient !
- Angèle, valise.
- Merci Brice !
Je réalise pas du tout
que je suis ici pour faire un show.
J’ai l'impression que là,
je vais juste aller faire du tourisme…
- Tournez à droite
sur Washinghton street.
T'aimes bien le petit bruit,
là, pour tes interviews ?
- Et j'aimerais
juste placer qu'Angèle
a fait une super vidéo
qu'elle aimerait montrer à Brut.
Une vidéo à Central Park.
Je chante :
"Englishman in New York"
mais en disant :
"Belgian girl in New York".
♪ I don't drink coffee,
I drink beer, my dear ♪
♪ I like my fries
With mayonnaise ♪
♪ Mayonnaise ♪
♪ And you can hear it
In my accent when I talk ♪
♪ I'm a Belgian girl
In New York ♪
♪ Oh, I'm an alien,
I'm a legal alien ♪
♪ I'm a Belgian girl
In New York ♪
- Ah, quelqu'un
a fait un petit rototo.
- Moi !
- Ah putain, il vient jusqu'ici !
- Pourquoi ? Ça sent l'ail ?
T'as mangé quoi ce midi ?
- Meuf, t'as bouffé quoi ?
- Des oignons.
- Fuck !
Beaucoup hein ?
- Ouais !
T'as préparé des mots
en anglais pour ce soir
ou tu veux que
je te fasse une petite liste ?
- Salut, enchantée.
Je m'appelle Angèle.
Je suis super contente
d'être ici à New York.
Non, je pense que
je vais parler en franglais.
- Ça va pas être
énervant du tout !
Parce que je sais
qu'il y a 92 %,
voire 99 % des gens
qui seront des Français.
Je suis hyper bien entourée.
Ma manageuse, Sylvie,
qui a été une baby-sitter,
qui est avant tout une amie
et une grande sœur.
Enfin, c'est vraiment quelqu'un
dont je suis très, très proche.
♪ Pa pa pa pa pa
pa pa pa pa pa pa pa ♪
En tout cas, le jour
où je prendrai la grosse tête,
je sais que Sylvie
sera la première
à me remettre
sur le droit chemin.
♪ I don't want
A lot for Christmas ♪
♪ There is just
One thing I need ♪
♪ I won't
Even wish for snow ♪
- On y est.
♪ I just wanna...♪
Yes !
- C'est son concert ce soir !
- Oh ! Qui chante ?
- C'est elle.
- Oh, félicitations !
♪ All I want for Christmas is you ♪
- Des fans américains !
Mais non, tu crois ?
- Je sais pas, je sais pas.
Oh mon dieu !
Oh, c'est fou ! Est-ce que
je peux te faire un câlin ?
- Bien sûr.
- Vraiment, je t'adore  !
J'ai une fan américaine !
- Ouais !
Angèle ?
- Ouais.
Il y a deux danseuses
qui sont restées coincées à Paris
et on sait pas pourquoi.
Elles ont pas
reçu leur visa et voilà.
Donc on sera
que trois sur scène.
Quelle histoire !
T'essayes
un petit peu tes sons
pour vérifier
qu'ils soient vaguement bons.
- Ok !
- Parce que
c'est pas ton piano habituel.
- Ah !
- Il va glisser.
- C'est un truc de location.
♪ On perd
De l'altitude toi et moi ♪
♪ Loin de nous... ♪
Moi, je m'estime
hyper chanceuse
d'être chanteuse en 2019
parce que en 2019,
c'est dans l'air du temps
d'avoir une voix
comme la mienne,
qui est une voix assez fragile.
♪ I kissed a girl
Just to try it ♪
Rien que
dans les années nonante…
Enfin, 90,
c'était plutôt les chanteuses
à voix qui étaient à la mode.
Et c'étaitvraiment
les chanteuses
plutôt à l'américaine,
qui avaient
de la puissance vocale.
Moi, j'ai absolument pas
de puissance vocale.
♪ C'est oui ou bien c'est non ♪
♪ Hier tu me voulais ♪
Et en même temps,
je pense que c'est ce qui à fait
que jusqu'ici, ça a plu,
parce que je pense que
c'est ce qui fait que
ma voix est reconnaissable.
Donc, j'essaie de ne pas
trop dénaturer tout ça.
Concrètement,
si on prend toute la liste...
Tu sais qu'il faut pas
bailler sans la main
parce que t'as un petit fantôme
qui met son...
*Rires*
Oh bah, il est content !
Tous les gens
qui travaillent avec moi
et avec qui
j'ai la chance de travailler,
c'est vraiment des gens proches
et c'est vraiment des gens
avec qui je pars en vacances,
que j'ai besoin de voir
et qui sont devenus
vraiment des piliers dans ma vie.
- Yes !
- Trop, non ?
- I love it. It's cool.
- Ouh là !
- C'est trop mais c'est cool.
- Oui.
- Tu vas te faire éclater
par les stylistes, là, je pense.
Mets-en
peut-être un tout petit.
Premier show à New York,
je me sens trop prête,
je suis trop contente.
Tu te sens trop prête,
t'es pas encore maquillée !
OphélieSecq,
qui est la maquilleuse,
c'est aussi
une sorte de grande sœur
depuis quelques mois.
Enfin, on se voit
tout le temps, c'est vraiment…
Elle, c'est ma maquilleuse
mais c'est aussi
la régisseuse artiste,
ça veut dire que c'est vraiment
ma maman sur la tournée.
C’est elle qui vient
me réveiller le matin
dans le tour-bus
avec un petit thé.
Et parfois, je me dis qu'elle
me materne un peu trop.
- Allô ?
- Ouais !
- Sound check
dans deux minutes ?
- Oui.
- Tranquilou.
Je suis toujours
super speed, super…
Et...
Je suis vite oppressée.
J'ai l'impression
d'entendre Roméo qui dit ça !
Mais c'est un peu vrai.
Je suis un peu comme lui.
Genre, je suis un peu genre…
méga stress et tout.
Je pense à mille trucs
en même temps.
Je n'arrive pas
à être focus sur un truc.
Allez !
- Mais attends,
moi je connais pas ça !
- Toïtoï !
T'es bien !
Deux fois !
- Toïtoï !
Dance ! Dance !
- C'est commencé ?
- Ouais.
- Ça a commencé !
♪ À quoi bon ? ♪
♪ T'es tellement seul
Derrière ton écran ♪
♪ Tu penses à
Ce que vont penser les gens ♪
♪ Mais tu les laisses
Tous indifférents ♪
Le fait de pouvoir faire
ma musique ici,
c'est juste une manière
d'accomplir quelque chose,
en fait,
un rêve un peu d'enfant.
♪ Mais tu voudrais
Qu'elle soit ta reine ce soir ♪
♪ Même si deux reines
C'est pas trop accepté♪
Quand j'étais
un peu plus jeune,
je me disais :
"Ah, j'aimerais bien revenir
et j'aimerais bien pouvoir
faire quelque chose."
Mais là,
j'ai encore plus de chance,
parce que j'y suis aussi pour
pouvoir faire mon métier.
Ça, ça change tout.
Merci !
Janinou,
c'était trop bien !
- Vous avez
assuré les filles, bravo !
- Trop bien !
On a tout ?
Moi j'ai l'impression
qu'on a tout oublié.
♪ Tout oublier ♪
Moi, j'ai un petit TOC.
Est-ce que...
Toutes les valises
ont été prises ?
Ok.
Je peux regarder ? Désolée !
Ouais, c'est bon.
Ok, merci.
J'ai des petits TOC, voilà.
Ça arrive à tout le monde.
Ça filme, là ?
Il fait hyper bon !
- Ben voilà pourquoi
j'aime pas la neige.
Pas du tout chargée !
J'adore ce jeu.
♪ Everything was going well
No obligation ♪
Le Canada,
ça fait déjà la troisième fois
qu’on vient ici à Montréal.
On était là il y a un an et demi
pour la première fois
sur une toute
petite scène gratuite
aux FrancoFolies de Montréal
et puis maintenant,
c'est une salle énorme.
On pensait pas du tout
qu'on arriverait à faire
une salle qui est
un équivalent de Zénith,
ici à Montréal.
♪ Tout est devenu flou ♪
♪ Un peu trop fou pour moi ♪
- Il y a Manon et Oomoo
qui n'avaient pas
leur visa à New York
et hier, on a eu l'information
qu'elles avaient
reçu leur passeport
et du coup, elles sont là,
à Montréal, ce soir.
Je pense qu'en terme d'énergie,
ça va être quelque chose
parce que là, d'être à New York
avec juste deux danseuses
au lieu de quatre,
c'était pas évident.
Donc, le lieu,
8000 personnes
et l'équipe au complet,
je pense que
ça va être quelque chose.
Ça va être cool.
Ok !
On me demande souvent
comment je me prépare
pour les concerts
et je pense que c'est
une grosse erreur de ma part,
mais je me prépare
pas vraiment, en fait.
Je pense qu'il y a 1 cm
d'huile dans mes pâtes.
Brillant ! Brightness !
Moi, j'ai toujours été
une grosse flemmarde
et donc, tout ce que
j'aime pas trop faire,
je le fais pas.
Ma vie,
leur vie.
Moi,
elles.
- Oh bitch!
- Allez, côté !
*Cris*
Wow.
Wow, wow !
Les gens,
ils crient, hein.
Tu peux montrer
qu'on se maquille
au-dessus des toilettes
par manque de place.
Mais c'est cool !
C'est vraiment cool !
Je mets votre version
ou je mets…
- Tu peux mettre la mienne,
elle est mieux.
Non, je rigole !
♪ Oh je t'aimerai encore ♪
Y'a un réel public à Montréal.
Moi, d'aller jouer ici, j'ai juste
l'impression d'être à la maison
dans le sens où
je sens une mentalité
très proche des Belges.
- Angèle ?
- Oui ?
- Elle est où, Ophé ?
- Je pense qu'elle mange.
-Non mais on refait du début.
On refait du début.
- Tu peux me stopper avec l'accent.
- Non parce que t'as le talent.
- T'as du talent !
T'as vraiment
du talent à revendre.
Toïtoï !
Bon, c'est notre dernier
concert de 2019.
- Ouais !
Franchement, ce soir :
"Brillance".
*Rires*
C'était hyper gai,
en l'espace d'une semaine,
de faire un petit club avec
des gens très proches,
avec une énergie très intense,
et trois jours plus tard faire
le Centre Bell,
qui est une salle immense.
♪ Tout le monde
Il veut seulement la thune ♪
♪ Et seulement ça
Ça les fait bander ♪
♪ Tout le monde
Il veut seulement la fame ♪
♪ Et seulement ça
Ça les fait bouger ♪
C'est pas possible que 8000 personnes
soient sur la même longueur d'onde,
mais j'ai l'impression
que les énergies des gens,
elles se mélangent
et ça forme un tout.
Et hier, ce tout, c'était incroyable.
♪ Beaucoup trop fou
Pour moi ♪
♪ Tout est devenu flou ♪
Y'a des chansons,
quand je les commence,
je vois plus les têtes
des gens, en fait.
Je vois plus que des téléphones
et j'en vois des milliers !
Je vois que des téléphones
et c'est bizarre.
Parfois, je me dis :
“Wow, est-ce qu'ils sont vraiment
en train de vivre le moment
ou est-ce qu'ils sont juste occupés
à regarder le concert à travers l'écran ?"
Et ça, j'avoue qu'à Montréal,
bizarrement, j'ai trouvé qu'ils étaient
pas trop sur leur écran.
♪ Balance ton quoi ♪
♪ Même si
Tu parles mal des filles ♪
♪ Je sais
Qu'au fond t'as compris ♪
♪ Balance ton quoi ♪
Bonjour, Brut !
Merci, Montréal !
Quand je t'ai vu pendant "La thune",
j'avais envie de pleurer.
C'est bon là,
on peut se reposer maintenant.
Et dernier concert
de 2019, hein !
Bravo !